we were we were French Protestants and
we were known as witches heretics
mumblers are you a magician in a sense
yes I don't do magic tricks we brought
together seven psychics I am a psychic I
am a psychic I am a psychic I am a
psychic I am a psychic I am a psychic I
am a psychic one is a liar
if the group discovers who the liar is
they'll split a cash prize
if the liar survives he or she wins the
entire prize
what's everybody zodiac sign before even
start Taurus Capricorn who has a website
dedicated to their psychic business at
the top of it it was more of just like
seeing who was answering very
generically or kind of piggybacking off
of what everyone else was saying okay
what makes you a psychic like what are
your gifts also specialized pathway
shooting John trajectory bones
mediumship tear somebody who is more
evolved is going to know what a star
seed is and so by identifying those that
we're familiar with that I knew for sure
was the real psychic yeah I've been to
all of the galaxies I had eight birth
marks on my body so those are galaxies
that you're from anybody else I know
about them I just don't subscribe I was
kind of nervous because I was like there
are so many aspects of how someone comes
to be a psychic and then it just it was
so heavy there were so many energies I
don't know what the right wing would be
to use but we had a vampire on stage I
[Music]
didn't like her energy I felt like
Breanna was trying too hard he knew that
I wrote his name so he made sure he
wrote mine because he was threatened by
me and that's what I'm used to since I
am a light worker and I do everything
with a pure intent and half of these
people up here do not do everything with
a pure intent so I was like oh wow
of course the light worker gets shunned
off first so when you do come into your
gifts okay so but also I studied so like
I will say like I did a lot of studying
like I went to New Orleans I learned how
to read bones does anyone use tools at
first I thought that I was going to be
the person that was
is asking like doing the most
interrogation but once he started I was
like great because I figured it could
work against a person
are we like part-time psychics are we
full-time full-time so part of my work
is you know using my psychic skills of
course but I don't do tarot readings and
all that good but I don't she didn't you
know she she reference a lot that she
did Reiki so I was like you're not
really mentioning like other abilities
she just stuck with Reiki and I was like
any Beverly Hills housewife does Reiki
do you have a spirit that you contact
prior to any sort of activity I do it
was no no it's my ancestry is very old
we date back in the United States to the
1500s
we were we were French Protestants and
we were known as witches heretics
mumblers spellcasters in a sense yes I
don't do magic tricks black or white
there's no such thing but call it what
you want people think of love light
magic and dark magic and really it's
just about intent I think they were
surprised because I wasn't all light and
love and my higher power do you have a
spiritual practice that you use and hone
in I'm a Reiki Master teacher I'm
certified and taught in about 15
different modalities I teach psychic
development I work with children and I
do Reiki attunement said men's prisons
women's prisons as well as Camille are
you a Reiki Master oh yes my which one
your symbol my symbol okay well first
I'll go with Shoku rain say hey kii I
didn't really see necessarily the
relevancy and we drawing Reiki symbols
and that kind of made me feel a little
bit suspicious on a more energetic level
like why is this person coming at me now
do you guys do any like distant work or
you just work with people in person I
have a few freezer spells at home right
now a freezer spell is a very important
aspect because it slows people down
those whom would wish negative energy
upon you you sort of write their name
and you freeze them you're physically
taking their energy and making it small
so they cannot they can't get out as
easily or rather they will leave you
alone quicker he's a character he does a
lot of like magic I wouldn't do I think
you can like that you can put blocks on
people I don't think that is and that is
and in terms of like I like anything
there's so many I learned in
anthropology there are so many racial
associations with the word that's why
what do you think you think of the bones
you think spirits
well she was so pretty and when I first
saw her I was like I think our model not
a psychic I noticed she started to
piggyback off of what everyone else was
saying and it was kind of just like so
what do you actually do with her
everything kept going back to being raki
raki raki raki raki and I thought I knew
the mole was still in here I knew I knew
I felt it I felt it i mitt mom I did
divination before I came here and
actually have it written down I was
looking for at the mall to be female
around the age 25 dark hair mixed-race
brown eyes her past her shoulders curly
I have it written down
yeah I can't the only thing is I put
straight hair though actually brown eyes
female about 25 yeah
so I'm not a psychic because I don't
have that clear ability to connect to a
higher consciousness at this time
because I know there's a lot of healing
that I need to do in order for that to
open up I knew your shoes position this
is beautiful but this is trying so hard
I knew upon arriving I felt it but
this is why it pays to follow your
intuition kids my bias based on probably
what the mole was wearing indicated to
me that she was probably a real psychic
because that's sort of how they dress I
shouldn't have left that kid in my mind
but I started second-guessing my own
divination I had done earlier $100 make
it Hollow
hey what I appreciated about this is
that it I really thought that this was
gonna be like you know a scene from
gladiator where we're all gonna try to
outside kick each other so I do think
that everyone led with questions and I
think we shared we shared light on the
stereotypes of what a psychic is so
hopefully people can learn from that I
watching this that's the end of this
episode
follow us on IG and we'll see you next
time